in this video we will discuss the
olfactory nerve or factory nerve or the
cranial nerve one is associated with the
sense of smell and starts from the nose
and ends into the primary and the
secondary olfactory cortex so this is a
section of the nose which also shows the
sinuses this is the frontal sinus this
is the sphenoidal sinus this is the
palate and above lies the cribriform
plate so the olfactory pathway begins
with the olfactory
rootlets now these olfactory reutlitz
are their nasal and have the olfactory
cells which pick up the smell and they
continue posteriorly as the olfactory
nerves the olfactory nerves pass through
the perforations in the cribriform plate
and they enter into the olfactory bulb
your factory bulb lies on the superior
part of the cribriform plate the
olfactory nerves enter the olfactory
bulb and hear the synapse with the
mitral and the tufted cells and the
processes of the mitral and the tufted
cells continue posteriorly as the
olfactory tract and this olfactory tract
continues posteriorly and enters into
the primary and the secondary olfactory
cortex so let's look at the section of a
brain to understand the central portion
of the olfactory pathway on the top
right corner of the screen you will see
a diagram of the brain and if we cut the
brain at this point and look at it from
below upwards this is the current
section that I am drawing here so this
is the olfactory bulb and the rest of
the portion that I am drawing here is
the rest of your factory pathway so here
are the olfactory reutlitz which enter
into the olfactory bulb and the
olfactory bulb sends the olfactory tract
which continuous posteriorly so this is
the olfactory tract the areas you are
seeing here are the medial or factorize
trial the lateral olfactories trial and
area just posterior to them is the
anterior perforated substance and this
area here forms the primary olfactory
cortex and the primary olfactory cortex
is associated with the active perception
of sense of smell these neurons continue
posteriorly and they enter into a area
known as the internal area and the area
just medial to it is the Uncas and these
two areas form the secondary or factory
cortex the secondary or factory cortex
is associated with functions like memory
and emotions associated with the sense
of smell so this was a short description
of the olfactory nerve and your factory
pathway also if you want to see more
videos on cranial nerves and other
topics don't forget to hit the subscribe
button below